With so many storylines to wrap up and character
arcs to complete, the final season of Game
of Thrones was bound to make bold moves that
not everyone agreed with.
Such was the case on the latest episode of
the fantasy drama, "The Last of the Starks,"
which has fans sulking, stamping their feet,
and setting the internet ablaze with criticism.
Major spoilers ahead!
The fourth episode of season 8 started out
strong, picking up after the jaw-dropping
victory over the Night King and his White
Walker army at the Battle of Winterfell to
show the survivors laughing, carousing, and
commending one another for their bravery and
strength.
Daenerys made Gendry Lord of Storm's End,
Tormund guzzled down wine like it was going
out of style, and the Lannister brothers goofed
off playing a drinking game with Brienne of
Tarth that eventually led to a steamy romance
scene.
Sadly, the merriment fizzled out as quickly
as it came and "The Last of the Starks" ended
up disappointing tons of die-hard Game of
Thrones fans.
"My heart is broken!"
"Don't touch me."
For starters, many kicked up a fuss over the
increasingly strained dynamic between Daenerys
and Jon Snow, who recently revealed to his
lady love that he's really her nephew and
the rightful heir to the Iron Throne.
Some felt that the tension between the two
— Daenerys wants the Iron Throne more than
anything and firmly requests Jon not tell
anyone about his true parentage, while Jon
doesn't have any interest in ruling the Seven
Kingdoms and tells Dany that he'll always
bend the knee to her — has become unbearable.
One fan took to Twitter to write that it's
"annoying" that Jon is letting his love for
Daenerys influence his decisions, while others
said that the Dany-Jon conflict is "frustrating"
because it seems a marriage between the two
would resolve problems and allow them both
to get what they desire.
Dany's "recklessness" and Jon's "naïveté"
were also sore spots for some fans.
Of course, that's just the tip of the dragon's
wing of problems fans had.
Viewers were heartbroken to see another one
of Daenerys' dragons plummet to his death
— this time Rhaegal, shot down by Euron
Greyjoy as Dany and her allied forces stormed
King's Landing.
One fan wrote on Twitter that Rhaegal's death
was a "lazy" surprise, tweeting,
"Like nobody saw the massive fleet of ships
that everybody then saw immediately?
Nobody thought to scout when you know they
have a massive fleet of ships?"
Another said in response,
"They've written themselves into a corner,
and have gotten incredibly lazy/sloppy with
the story.
They could have easily killed Rhaegal [because]
Dany saw the ships, and in her hubris went
in charging not knowing about all the arrows.
Simple change, much more plausible."
Rhaegal's gnarly demise wasn't the only shocking
death in the episode.
As punishment for Daenerys not giving up her
crusade for the Iron Throne, and to send her
a message about what she'll do if she doesn't
surrender, Cersei Lannister had the Mountain
behead Dany's loyal adviser Missandei, who
had been taken prisoner when Euron and his
Iron Fleet ambushed Dany's ships.
Unsurprisingly, Missandei's murder sent shockwaves
through social media, with many stating that
she "deserved so much better" and others expressing
distress over the fact that her lover Grey
Worm is now living his worst nightmare.
The indignation didn't stop there — more
Thrones fans let it be known that they were
disappointed over Jon sending his direwolf
Ghost north of the Wall without even patting
his head to say goodbye, Tyrion and Varys
contemplating committing treason and considering
withdrawing their support for Dany in favor
of Jon after they learn who Jon truly is,
and Jaime abandoning Brienne and heading for
Cersei in King's Landing shortly after the
two knights shared several intimate evenings
together.
All this anger and sadness over Season 8,
Episode 4 of Game of Thrones has resulted
in a grim consequence: the episode is currently
the second-lowest-rated Thrones installment
in history based on Rotten Tomatoes reviews.
The episode stands at a 61 percent approval
rating on the aggregator site, coming in only
a few percentage points above the disturbing
season 5 episode "Unbowed, Unbent, Unbroken,"
which earned a score of 54 percent.
Game of Thrones has only two episodes remaining
in its entire run, and it's anyone's guess
how the show is going to bounce back from
this perceived low point — especially now
that Daenerys is on the brink, Team Targaryen
is down two important members, Dany's trusted
advisers could turn their backs on her at
any moment, and Jaime is plotting something
big.
For the sake of viewers' wellbeing and in
hopes that Thrones will go out on a high note,
we have our fingers crossed that the upcoming
episode doesn't ruffle quite as many feathers
as this one did.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.